estas tierras del cultivo por las que
camina olga han sido históricamente
conocidas como la canasta del pan
ucrania es uno de los mayores
exportadores de grano no sólo a europa
sino también a áfrica y medio oriente la
alimentación mundial está en riesgo con
la invasión rusa ucrania perdió tienda
web en la guerra no ayuda a las cosechas
ni al grano es malo para la exportación
y para los cultivos esta tierra provee a
nuestra gente con pan y comida tiene que
continuar en paz y es que
aunque la guerra aún no ha llegado aquí
las consecuencias se sienten en los
cultivos en la producción tanto a grande
como a pequeña escala en este campo
agrícola las cosechas se han reducido a
la mitad por falta de fertilizantes
irrigación y semillas material es muy
difícil trabajar estos días estamos
cortos de fertilizantes y semillas ya
que nuestros proveedores están en la
región de quien fijar son no podemos
transportarlos hasta aquí juárez del
trata y fútbol cree en el mismo en esta
cooperativa agrícola trabaja la mitad de
sus empleados ya que muchos se han unido
a las fuerzas de defensa territorial
oleksiy es ingeniero mecánico y ahora él
mismo tiene que reparar los tractores
porque sus mecánicos están defendiendo
las fronteras de odessa
tenemos que estar preparados no podemos
detener la actividad por la guerra
tenemos que seguir produciendo para
seguir alimentando a ucrania de esa
chance de hoy
nuestros
nuevos toques
científicos como olga ingenieros y
agricultores como vitales que no están
luchando en la línea del frente pero sí
están trabajando sin parar en el campo
para garantizar la seguridad alimentaria